[Music]
all right let's share one more great
story before to say goodbye which is
what I'm
[Applause]
liking practically every school library
has them I'm talking about the Ordinary
People Change the World book series from
author Brad Meltzer and illustrator
Chris eliopoulos the series covers icons
from Abraham Lincoln to Rosa Parks and
has sold over 7even million copies their
latest is I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg
profiling the late Supreme Court Justice
it's out now and it marks the 10th
anniversary of the series so on the line
right now to talk about it is author
Brad melter give it up for him y'all
welcome back to the show
Brad so these books we've talked about
that are so successful how does this
feel man uh it feels like my family
bought a lot of copies is what it feels
like the truth is is it's humbling uh we
started this series as you know to give
our kids better Heroes to look up to and
it's amazing to watch now 7 million
parents and kids reading the books we're
going on a nationwide Tour 12 cities
Linda Carter who played Wonder Woman's
going to have be with us in Virginia
Temple grandon is going to be with us in
Colorado we're going to Atlanta and
Texas and Florida and everywhere in
between meeting parents and kids who are
determined to make the world a better
place with a bit more decency in it
because man that's what we need right
now right Kelly absolutely uh well the
latest book I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg you
actually knew her right I did it's it's
the only hero we've done who I knew
before we did a book on her and I know
her because her daughter was actually
one of my mentors when I was in school
and the other thing that's crazy is one
of her clerks when she was a Supreme
Court justice was one of my best friends
so at my friend's wedding her uh
Witnesses for the marriage certificate
to sign the marriage certificate were
myself and Justice Ginsburg and so we're
sitting in the room and she signs the
marriage certificate and there goes
Justice Ginsburg signs her name and I
look at my friend and I'm like do you
really need me at this point do you
really want my
signature that's amazing all right so
what do you want kids to take away from
this you know I think that when we think
of Ruth b Ginsburg we think of this like
stately Supreme Court justice but we
forget when she was just a girl Ruth b
Ginsburg liked going roller skating she
liked climbing trees and having
Adventures but this was something back
then that girls weren't supposed to do
it was boys who had the adventures it
was even the books she used to read boys
would go climbing trees and jumping all
over the place and the girls would wear
pretty pink dresses and sit there and
watch and it was her mother who broke
that stereotype her mom when she was a
little girl used to take her to the
library and every Friday said you could
pick out five books and her favorite
books were the books about real heroes
Amelia arheart Harriet Tubman and it was
those Heroes like her mother who taught
her that same lesson there is absolutely
nothing that a girl can't do and I want
my daughter to have that lesson I want
my sons to have that lesson I want
everyone and and here's the finale of
the book it says today they call me a
Trail Blazer but the best part of
Blazing the trail is leaving tracks that
means you're not just doing things for
yourself you're leaving a path for
others to follow start with one voice
and let it grow into a chorus I am Ruth
b Ginsburg create equality create
Justice absolutely thank you so much
Brad we love having you on the show love
this new book I am Ruth Bader Berg is
out now and everyone is going home with
a
coffee for more information on where you
can meet Brad and illustrator chopus
head socials thank you so much Brad I'm
liking your post right now that's not
all our season long partner pip and
makers of G2 the go to k the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate your
book series and the life of Justice
Ginsburg so what they're going to do is
they're going to ride a check for $1,000
to the Women's Suffrage National
Monument Foundation
we know you're a big supporter so trying
to get that built in Washington DC right
now thank you so much BR thank you to
all our guest is Alex John PRI Joe
Danielle CIS Bita Mr Freeman and Tre you
have a great it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
Chang thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home